hilda milito paul affective effet est
effectivement tombé sous le contrôle des
troupes russes après d'intenses combats
avec l'armée ukrainienne le drapeau
russe a d'ailleurs été positionné sur un
édifice officielle de cette ville mais
ce n'est pas la seule prise par les
troupes russes de ces dernières 24
heures un peu plus à l'ouest donc très
très peu loin de la crimée il y à un
barrage très important que les russes
ont pris contrôle désormais c'est
s'appelle le barrage de carson et ce
barrage est très important pour la
crimée pourquoi parceque ils alimentent
la crimée en eau douce et depuis
l'annexion de la crimée par les russes
en 2014 et bien les ukrainiens avaient
réduit le débit
en eau douce donc et ça poser certains
problèmes évidemment pour les habitants
de cette presqu'île autre prise très
importante et très stratégique de
l'armée russe une centrale
hydroélectrique sur le fleuve dniepr a
été prise à rakoff cas est désormais les
russes contrôlent toute cette région qui
se situent quelque peu au nord de la
crimée maintenant les russes avancent
aussi bien vers le nord que vers l'est
vers l'est où se situe le port de
marioupol où nous ont été rapportés
cette nuit d'intenses bombardements dans
la périphérie de ce port très
stratégique qui se situe sur la mer
d'azov et dont on nous a aussi rapporté
beau de qu'il y avait eu des blessés
parmi les civils c'est une ville d'à peu
près un million d'habitants qui revêt
une position stratégique pourquoi parce
qu'elle se situe à cheval sur les deux
rives du dniepr qui est le cru au grand
fleuve de l'ukraine qui coupent
l'ukraine du nord au sud le fleuve que
vous pouvez voir derrière moi et sur
cette ville évidemment se trouvent
plusieurs grands ponts et ses ponts et
bien peut-être pourront peut-être
peut-être à l'avenir stratégique d'un
point de vue militaire parce qu'on l'a
vu du côté de kiev l'armée ukrainienne a
coupé a tenté de couper l'avancé des
blindés russes en faisant sauter
plusieurs ponts dans la région de la
capitale ce n'est pas encore le scénario
qui est privilégiée dans la région nous
trouvons nous nous trouvons mais cela
est possible c'est à dire que qui
maîtrisent les ponts aujourd'hui
maîtrise peut-être la suite de cette
guerre entre la russie et l'ukraine pour
l'instant les troupes russes sont plutôt
basée sur la rive orientale et l'air
mais craint évidemment essaye de tout
faire pour les empêcher de traverser